hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to discuss
two body operators in second
quantization in another one of our
videos on rigorous quantum mechanics
in the video on one body operators we
learn how we can write them in terms of
creation and annihilation operators that
allow us to capture
all the subtleties associated with
systems of identical particles
today we're extending this analysis to
two body operators which include the
important example
of the coulomb interaction between two
particles let's go
this is the second video on how to write
down operators using second quantization
and the focus is on two body operators
today the discussion builds on the video
on one body operators
so if you haven't seen that one yet just
follow the link in the description and
come back to this one after that
today we start with the state space of
two particles given by the tensor
product of v
q with v q prime we also consider an
operator g
q q prime that acts on this two particle
state space
for a system of n particles the total
state space is given by the tensor
product
of all single particle states of which
this two particle space
is a subspace for the operator we can
promote
g q q prime to act on the full state
space in the usual manner by considering
its tensor product
with the identities of all other single
particle states
but as always we simplify the notation
and emit the identity operators
operators like g here that act on two
particles at the time include the
important example of the coulomb
interaction
between two charged particles if we now
move to a system of n
identical particles we know that
exchanging any two particles leads to
exactly the same physics so that our
state space is no longer v
but instead a subspace of v spanned by
totally symmetric states for bosons
or totally anti-semitic states for
fermions
in a similar fashion the operators that
act on a system of identical particles
must stay the same when we exchange any
two particles which means that we must
work with totally symmetric operators on
the particle exchange
in the case we're looking at today of
operators that act on two particles at a
time
we obtain a symmetric operator capital g
by setting it equal to one half
sum over q and q prime from one to n
of g q q prime and we insist that q must
differ from q prime
this sum runs over all q two prime pairs
from one to n
so the action of this operator doesn't
change when we exchange any two
particles
we have to insist that q is different
from q prime because the term where they
are equal
is in reality a term that acts on a
single particle and that is already
covered in the video on one body
operators
in this expression for g we have
included a factor of one half here
but this factor is just a number so it
doesn't really change any of the physics
of particle exchange we could have
picked any other constant and the
physics would be the same
but we choose a half because it leads to
more convenient mathematical expressions
down the line
an operator like capital g acts on all n
particles
however it is made of individual
operators that only act on two particles
at a time
and an operator like this is typically
called a two body operator
similar to what we saw for one body
operators working with two body
operators in first quantization leads to
a very large number of terms which makes
mathematical manipulations cumbersome
therefore the objective of today's video
is to write a two body operator
in second quantization in terms of
creation and annihilation operators if
you remember the video on one body
operators the derivation there used the
symmetrized and unsymmetrized tensor
products which made it rather long and
tedious
today it is much simpler because it
builds on the results we already got for
one body operators
instead of dealing with symmetrized and
anti-symmetrized tensor products they
were going to deal directly with
creation and annihilation operators
this will actually be very good practice
for us to become more familiar with
manipulations involving creation and
annihilation operators which is
something essential
when we work in the second quantization
formulation of quantum mechanics
in fact this is precisely the very first
thing we're going to do we start by
playing around with creation and
annihilation operators to derive a very
useful result that we need later on
here i have the commutation relation for
bosons and the anti-commutation relation
for fermions
two things about these expressions first
i am replacing
a ui dagger and aui by ai dagger and ai
like we have done a few times before to
simplify notation and all that happened
is that we implicitly understand that
we're always working in the same basis
second we typically use the letter a for
creation annulation operators of bosons
and the letter c for fermions however
today we're going to use the letter
a for both types of particles so replace
ci
and ci dagger by ai and ai dagger for
fermions
we do this because we're going to write
compact expressions that are valid for
both bosons and fermions as long as you
remember the correct commutator or
anti-commutator algebra for each type of
particle
let's start with bosons we can spell out
the commutation relation as
a k a j dagger minus aj dagger
a k equals delta j k this implies that
a k aj dagger is equal to aj dagger a
k plus delta j k for fermions we have
the corresponding anti-commutation
relation
and we can also rearrange it to get a k
aj dagger equal to minus
aj dagger ak plus delta jk
we can write a single expression
capturing both bosons and fermions like
this
well we have introduced the eta factor
which is plus 1 for bosons and minus one
for fermions
we can derive a similar expression when
both operators are annihilation
operators
in the case of bosons they commute so
that akal
equals alak while for fermions
they anticommute so a k a l
equals minus a l a k
we can again combine them to a k a l
equal to eta
a l a k the real expression we want to
derive is the following
consider the product of four terms a i
dagger
a k aj dagger a l
this here in the middle is simply a k aj
dagger that we have up
here so we can substitute in this result
and we get this
multiplying through we get this term
plus this term in the first term we can
see that these two annihilation
operators are given
by this so we can rewrite the whole
expression as e to the squared
a i dagger a j dagger a l a k
plus the second term which doesn't
change so delta j k a i dagger
a l it is squared equals one
so we actually get the exact same result
for both bosons and fermions like this
and this is true as long as we remember
that the creation and annihilation
operators obey the corresponding
commutation or anti-commutation
relations and this is of course the
reason why we insisted on writing
compact expressions valid for both
these sort of manipulations are
extremely useful when working in second
quantization
so you should be comfortable with them
you never need to remember
any of these relations all you need is
to be confident in the manipulation of
these operators
so you can derive them quickly when you
need to moving forward what we will need
today
is that this product of four operators
here is equal to this sum over two terms
here
so now let's move to the real point of
the video which is to write a two body
operator
in second quantization let's start with
a special case
let's imagine that the two particle
operator g q
q prime can be factorized such that it
is equal
to the product of two single particle
operators
f q times h q prime
as we discussed at the beginning of the
video we write the totally symmetric
two body operator g as equal to one half
sum over q and q prime
of g q q prime for two different from q
prime
we can then substitute the assumption
we're making up here about the
factorized form of the two particle
operator
and we can write it as a half
multiplying sum over q
of fq times the sum of a q prime of
hq prime minus the sum over q of
fq h2 you should convince yourself that
this expression is correct but very
briefly
the original sum omits the terms when q
equals q prime
in this first term here we have all
possible cross terms and this includes q
equal to q
prime so what we need is this second
term here that removes the q equals q
prime term
before moving on we also know that this
here is the product of two operators
acting on the same state
in subspace v q so we can write it as f
h
sub q to emphasize this fact and you can
think of f h
as another operator that is the product
of the first two with this in mind
each of these three terms here here and
here
are now simply one body operators
remember from the corresponding video
that one body operators f
are given by the sum over all single
particle operators
and we can write one body operators in
second quantization as equal to the sum
over i
k of the matrix element f i k and then
the creation operator
a i dagger and the inhalation operator a
k
where the matrix element f i k is given
by u i
f u k using this result
we can write g as equal to one half
then the sum over i k of f i k a
i dagger a k sum over j l of
h j l a j dagger a l
minus sum over i l of the matrix element
of the product f h with indices i l
times a i dagger a l
the indices i j k l are of course dummy
indices because they appear in the sums
so the choices i have made here are
simply for convenience
we can now move this sum and matrix
element to the beginning and we rewrite
the whole expression like this
to make some room for the rest of the
derivation let me erase the working we
had up to now
and let me copy up here the latest
expression we got for g
now this product over four operators is
exactly this expression up here
that we conveniently derived early on so
we can replace it to get first this sum
with two creation and two annihilation
operators
then this sum of recreation and
annihilation operator
and then we still have this last term
here that we copy as is
let's focus for a moment in this middle
term the delta function means that we
can perform the sum of a j
straight away and we end up with the sum
over i k l
of u i f u k u k
h u l and then the creation operator ai
dagger and the inhalation operator al
i have explicitly written out the
expression for the matrix element
because now i can move the sum over k
to the middle here and i get a sum over
the outer product of uk with uk
which is simply the resolution of the
identity this means i get sum over i
l of the matrix element u i product of f
with
h u l times a i dagger a
l this is just the matrix element of the
product f
h with indices i l so this last
expression is now equal to this third
term up here
so that the middle term cancels with
this third term
this means that we can write a two body
operator given by the symmetry sum over
g
q q primes as equal to one half
and then a sum of a four indices of the
matrix elements
f i k h j l and then a i dagger a j
dagger a l a k this result of course is
true
under the assumption that we can
factorize the two particle operator g
q q prime into two one particle
operators f q
and h q prime
so now we have this expression for a two
body operator in the special case where
the two particle operators g q q prime
can be factorized
extending this to the general case is
actually straightforward we can always
write a general two particle operator g
q q prime as an expansion over products
of one particle operators with some
expansion coefficients
the factorization up here is a special
case of this general form
in which all expansion coefficients c
are zero apart from one of them
you should convince yourself that you
can always write any two particle
operator like this
but just to give you a simple example
consider a one dimensional two particle
operator that has a harmonic form
x1 minus x2 all squared which is a very
common potential in physics
so how can we write that a sum over
products of one particle operators
in this simple example we can expand the
square to get these four terms
each of the terms is a product of some
power of x1 and some power of x2 with
some coefficients in front
so it is indeed of this form here so
let's go back to the two body operator
g first it is equal to this
replacing the expression here of g q q
prime in this sum
we get this
we can now move the sum over alpha beta
to the front and we get this rearranged
expression
each of the terms in the sum for any
alpha or beta is of the same form as
this term up here for the product of two
one particle operators
this means that we can use the result we
got for the special case when the two
particle operator could be factorized
and we get one half sum over alpha beta
of the expansion coefficients
and then some over i j k l of the matrix
elements of
f alpha and h beta
and then the sequence of four operators
a i dagger aj dagger
a l a k for the final step
we first need to consider the matrix
elements of the two particle operator
g q q prime we write them as g
i j k l and set them equal to this
bracket
in the two particle tensor product space
replacing the expression up here for g q
q prime
we get sum over alpha beta of c alpha
beta
of the matrix element of f alpha times
the matrix element
of h beta this expression for the matrix
element is precisely what we have up
here
if we combine the sum over alpha beta of
c alpha beta
together with these two matrix elements
what this means is that we can replace
all the terms that depend on alpha beta
by the matrix
element g i j k l and it is precisely
what we will do in the final slide
as promised we can finally write the two
body operator g
it is a symmetric operator given by this
sum over all pairs of particles
and we can write it as equal to one half
sum over i
j k l of g i j k l
a i dagger aj dagger a l a k
and g i j k l is the matrix element of
the two particle operator in the
corresponding two particle tensor
product space
so this is the final answer this is how
we write down a two body operator in
second quantization
the expression is valid for both bosons
and fermions and although today we have
been using the symbol a for both
in general we will go back to using a
for bosons and c for fermions
so before we wrap up how can we
conceptually understand what the
operator does
we start with two particles in states k
and l and end up with two particles in
states i
and j and the matrix element tells us
the amplitude associated with this
transition
if we compare this interpretation to the
one we discussed in the video on one
body operators
we see that they are very similar one
body operators induce transitions of
single particles from one state to
another
whereas two body operators induce
transitions of pairs of particles
from two initial states to two final
states
the very last thing i want to note is
that the order of the terms is important
in particular the matrix element here
has the order kl
whereas here the order is lk of course
this doesn't matter for bosons because a
l and ak commute but it matters for
fermions because they anticommute so
there is an x or minus sign
if you exchange the order of the terms
one and two body operators pretty much
cover all the operators that you'll
encounter in physics
when written in second quantization they
provide a very compact form
and a very powerful formalism to study
systems of many identical particles
and i encourage you to check the many
applications of second quantization in
the videos linked in the description if
you like the video or like send me
suggestions for future videos
please subscribe